[Music]
okay well so what's next at Okada
technology we could answer robots and AI
here are some of our robots and here is
one of our huge warehouses full of
robots running to pick up goods to
fulfill thousands of orders per day you
might wonder who is Oka dough now Okada
has been an online retailer in UK since
15 years as a customer you can go to our
website our app to place your order we
can help you do so by recommending of
some of your regular products or new
ones and maybe one day a self-driving
car will reach you home but meanwhile
thousands of Pickers and drivers are
working to make this happen
ok dough is also now more than just a
retailer it's also a tech company robust
enough to share is technology so we can
share with you if you are retailer from
the website and the app to the full
system of delivery using our fully
automated warehouses and more big data
and AI some of the biggest retailer in
the in the world are already with us on
this adventure like Morrison's in UK
bomb Peru in Spain Casino in France
subways in Canada Inca in Sweden and
Kroger here in United States
ok now let's jump to some examples of
machine learning and AI that can help
this online retail business product
recognition for now our pickers or
robots need to find where the barcode of
the products are in order to identify
them for picking using image recognition
we could speed up this process and
improve its accuracy by just by passing
this problem of needing to find where
the barcode is and there is more with
such technology we could also provide to
the customer the possibility
to just take photos of the products they
want to add to our baskets another
example of machine learning that can be
used is for demand forecasting to
deliver thousands of orders per day
properly we need to anticipate the
demand
how many orders will be placed every day
that can shaitaan on during the week the
weekend during holidays or more
specially on Christmas and if you can
also more precisely predict how many
products of each kind will be demanded
every day you will also better
anticipate the supply chain and in this
kind of problems machine learning can
help for example
product recommendation have you run out
of some of your regular products would
you also like some complementary
products with the one in your baskets
would you rather like one product
instead of another one machine learning
can help and the last example that we
will detail more into this presentation
is a classical problem that we face in
online retail that is fraud detection
orders being delivered but never paid
for or being delivered paid for but then
the the money is required back and this
is called charge back and this happens
in general when the credit card used was
it stolen one okay now let's enter into
more detail into this fraud detection
problem and start setting the contexts
ok the retail in UK is more than fifty
thousand products more than 650 thousand
customers more than 250 thousand orders
per week so imagine you only have one
failed payment out of 1,000 orders is
already means losing millions of dollars
on the other hand if you can improve
just by a few percentage your fraud
detection system you can save tens of
thousands of dollars with one big
warning false positive if you predict
that one order will be fraudulent and
it's not because it's a regular customer
this high has higher costs because a
regular customer that will stop buying
with you is a lot of possible future
orders that you are losing and not just
one and possibly some fame and so I told
you now we have on board much more
retailers from all around the world so
this number just multiplied okay so how
can we face this kind of problem of
fraud detection historically we have
been using a set of handmade rules set
of rules like for example if you place
more than three orders for the future
for more than five hundred pounds and
you let us less than 24 hours for the
delivery well your order is risky you
combine a letter a lot of rules like
that you give you a score that gives a
risk potential of your orders so this
this kind of system is based on
intuitions human intuitions human can in
general define 10-20-30 rules based on
10 20 features each rule is based on one
two three four conditions and in general
it's kind of fixed set of rules other
possible approach is machine learning
you if you derive features from your
incoming orders like how many passed
orders of the customer what's the total
amount of your baskets
was the time between the order and the
delivery and you pass all this feature
along with the non class of failed
payment or not to a machine learning
algorithm that we learn a model that
will then be able to predict if a new
incoming order will be associated with
failed payments or not this system is
based on data instead of intuitions and
can handle much more rules much more
features much more conditioned on rules
and it is adaptable you can relearn
regularly your machine learning model
and it will take into account the lasts
behavior of fraudster that can evolve
with time
okay so we run some analysis on the
different machine learning algorithm
available and I put here on two axis the
reason that we we have is on the
vertical axis is the predictive
performance of the models and xD boosts
like many times in cackle competition
and in real life extra boost is reaching
the best predictive performance and then
tensorflow neural network has also
interesting results and I put on the
horizontal axis another aspect that is
important in for detection that it
explained ability if your algorithm can
explain why he thinks that one order is
for uhland or not for example because
the the content of the basket is is is
not normal or if the payment methods
used seems suspicious it will help the
human and if you want to use this
machine learning algorithm to make
automated decisions for legal reasons
you need to be explained why he rejected
one order so obviously on these second
aspects the handmade rules are the the
best it's more understandable for humans
but the rule induction algorithms are
really close decision tree also
understandable but sometimes the depth
of the tree is is too high for a human
to really apprehend it okay here is an
important thing I am a data scientists I
know quite a lot about machine learning
neural networks how to cluster data the
duplicate data how to face an unbalanced
class problems how to configure
parameters of neural networks or others
but I don't know quite anything about
machine settings networks topology
clustering machine replicate data load
balancing configure server so the main
question is how can I know go from my
big data lying in some data Lake into a
fully automated pipeline of machine
learning serving predictions for from
detection in prediction hopefully easily
and quickly but most importantly
and with no need to set up a lot of
machines and containers and auto-scaling
processes etc with one main constraint
that is real time fraudster don't lose
time if they steal a credit card they
will try to use it to place five orders
for a high amount and for short notice
so imagine we have a model that just
choose two features how many pass orders
for the customer and how many future
orders for the customer a training time
it's easy we are we have the access to
all data we can derive the feature from
the input pass it to the machine
learning model algorithm that we'll
learn a model at serving time now it can
be more complicated the number of passed
orders can be something that has been
pre computed and exposed to get the
information directly at real time the
number of feature orders can be more
complicated because since the fraudster
can place a lot in real time you need to
be closer to real time so you need one
set of features pre-computed another one
in real time and combine them to provide
as input to the machine learning model
exactly the same as a straining time so
tell me przemek do you have some good
solution to handle my problems and maybe
with some Google tools thank you the
wrong I will try to do just that first
of all thank your for coming and we will
now see how we can implement the
solution for a fraud detection problem
using Google cloud platform and of
course as Lauren said we would like it
to be as easy as possible so let's do
this but first of all I would like you
to imagine where we want to be at the
end of the journey what's what are the
actual physical components that are that
will be in play here so on the left side
here what you can see is order
management micro service a couple smart
broad platform is powered by hundreds of
micro services like this each of them
has very clearly defined
responsibilities and here as the name
suggests order management deals with
orders being placed this service one
that when the order is being placed
would like to know whether this order is
fraudulent or not so what it will do it
will consult other micro service let's
call it fraud service by sending it
customer ID and all details about the
order and what it would like to get in
return is what is the probability of
this order being fraudulent and the
fraud service is actually the component
that we are trying to build so please
keep this image in mind so this is where
we are heading to you what if you've
never done machine learning project how
would you even start where do you begin
so of course there is no machine
learning without data you need a fair
amount of history to be able to learn
patterns from the behaviors of your
customers to do that you need the right
set of tools to store and process the
data and since we're talking about
Google platform called platform there is
a really good analytical database that
we would like to use and it's Google
bigquery we as a cuddle store all our
data and bigquery so it's it's petabytes
of data actually and bigquery scales to
this amount seamlessly the other thing
that we really like about bigquery is
that how fast this we can write SQL
queries run them over terabytes of data
and still get results in terms of
minutes or even seconds the other good
thing is that it doesn't require you to
have separate DBA team to manage
bigquery it just load they tend to be
query you run queries and that's all
that is there and the last thing that
kind of sold the query to us is the
pricing policy and BIC where you pay for
storage and in terms of SQL queries you
pay for the amount of data the
have read so it's a very fair policy and
it really helps us to control the cost
that we spent on doing analytics and
there are two questions remaining so we
decided that we want to use bigquery as
a main storage so the first question is
how do we actually load the data and
bickering and the one which is even more
fundamental what data do you land in
bigquery so in the data like you would
like to store all the data but what all
means in this case so the rule of thumb
that we use in okada which is really
working very well for us is that when
there is any change the business state
of the application you should send or
rather the Microsoft servers responsible
for that business State should send an
event to a distributed queue which
corresponds to the change when we gather
all this data the small Delta's then
when we go back in time you are able to
see what was the exact state of the
whole system at any particular point in
time so here is the diagram of the
ingestion pipeline on the left you see
all those micro services that I told you
about they are actually running in
Amazon Web Services and we use Google
server AWS kinases for distributed queue
then there is a question how do we
transport data from a distributed queue
to bigquery and we wrote a streaming
application using Apache beam and Google
dataflow which is running 24/7 and it's
moving the data in real time and then we
use streaming inserts into bigquery to
store this data if you don't know what
Apache beam or Google dataflow is let me
spend a few minutes on telling you more
about this for that I will use a toy
example let's imagine you have a
collection of words maybe you took a
Shakespeare novel and you split it to
have an itch word that isn't in this
novel and you would like to count how
many of those words start with a letter
a or letter B C etc if you were to write
this using for example Java streams you
would probably write a snippet like the
one on the top you would first extract
first character out of each word group
by this character and then for each
group count the amount of items in this
group and in Apache beam it's very
similar
you just write very exactly the same
transformations you have a map which
extracts first character out of the word
you group by and then you count an
Apache beam is just a programming model
for transforming the data it kind of
like a Java streams because how it
actually executes its dependent on JVM
in case of Java streams and it's the
same with beam you just write this code
and how you execute it it depends on
execution framework that you choose and
there are plenty of executions for
frameworks that you can choose from
ranging from Apache apex to Apache gear
pump the one that we use is Google
dataflow mostly because it's well
integrated with other Google cloud
services but it's also
semi managed you still have control over
machines configuration but most of the
time you just write a Java code you
upload to Google dataflow and it just
runs great we have all our data and
bigquery so the next step that the wrong
or anyone working on machine learning
algorithm would do is probably to go
there and explore what's data available
you need to see what are the
distributions of different variables how
they how different tables join with each
other
you can ask different questions about
your data for example you can ask
whether people that have lot amount of
alcohol in the orders are more likely to
be fraudsters than the other people and
a really great tool to
do that exploratory analysis is bigquery
because first of all we already have
data there it has web UI where you can
just go type a query and get a result
fast and based on the result you can
formulate another query and iterate
iterate to the point where you have all
the answers for it to your questions if
you need to do more deep analysis maybe
plot some charts share the results with
on other people there are other tools in
Google cloud platform that allow you to
do that one I would like to mention is
Google data data lab where you which is
basically a hosted Jupiter notebook you
write a Python code there you can
extract data from bigquery you can plot
charts with whatever libraries that are
are available in Python environment you
can use pound as you can use the
scikit-learn you can use plotly whatever
you want and there's also another tool
from Google called Google collaboratory
that you see here which is kind of
taking this idea of notebooks one step
further so in Google collaboratory the
Jupiter notebook is just a file on
Google Drive and you can do whatever you
do with such a Google Drive files with a
Jupiter notebook here so we can share it
you can put comments in here many people
can collaborate on the same notebook at
the same time we use it a lot in Aikido
especially for doing reviews on
notebooks and we find it very handy at
this point we are ready to jump into ml
we will do a feature engineering so
we'll extract meaningful information out
of row data and will train and model but
first which model do you choose here is
the slide that Lauren already showed you
and Lauren told you that there are two
things that we care about one is
accuracy on the y axis and the other one
is explained ability which you can see
here on the x axis but to be honest
there's also third dimension here which
we need to take into account and this is
how easy it
to deploy those solutions to the cloud
Google cloud platform offers you a cloud
machine learning this is a service that
was first designed to train and serve
neural nets who've written in tensorflow
how this works exactly you ride your
tensorflow code you package it into a
Python package you put it on Google
Cloud storage and then you just call a
cloud machine learning API you say
here's my package with tensorflow here's
the input data please train a model for
me and then the trained model is just
another file on Google Cloud storage so
then you can point cloud machine
learning to this model and you can say
please serve it for me
so what cloud machine learning will do
it will create a rest endpoint that you
can call in real time you just give it
all the features and you get predictions
back sometimes ago Google announced that
cloud machine learning will support
other other algorithm except of
tensorflow
so there is a support for serving XG
boost and scikit-learn models
unfortunately there is no way to train
them yet on the cloud and of course you
can use CPUs GPUs for training all this
stuff so to sum up the neural networks
are now really easy to deploy to the
cloud thanks to cloud machine learning
it's not so easy when it comes to XG
boost and scikit-learn because you still
need to take care of the training by
yourself and if you were to use the role
induction the c-5 program which is was
written in C++ we really have no
out-of-the-box way to running on the
cloud if we were to do this would
probably package it into docker
container run on Google container engine
with kubernetes but this will require
lots of work from a lot of fine tuning
so given all of that information we made
a conscious decision that we will
sacrifice explain ability for now so
it's not that we don't care about it but
to get us faster to production we'll
start with something which is easy
to deploy to the cloud and since neural
nets are easy to deploy and still have
pretty good accuracy this is what we
went for all right so we have chosen a
male model it's now time to Train it and
here's how the training pipeline looks
like on the high level so we have events
that I told you about before so each
corresponds to their single change the
business state of the application out of
those we need to extract meaningful
information for example how many failed
transactions did this customer have in
the past and for that we use primarily
bigquery so we wrote SQL queries that
transform this data and store them in
bigquery as a set of tables at some
point we saw that those SQL became hard
to manage so that we decided to rewrite
some of those transformations into a
data flow again using Apache beam and
when we have all of these and bigquery
we can just run Cloud ml training and
obtain a trained model of course in the
Martian learning it's very rare case
that you just train a model once and
deploy usually what you do is you
refresh the model and to do that you
need some way to schedule and
orchestrate your training pipeline when
we started with DCP 5 years back there
was no out-of-the-box solution ready in
Google cloud platform so we wrote our
own we called it for a manager and it's
appengine application that takes care of
all of that fortunately fortunately for
you if your start starting right now
there is now hosted Apache air flow
which goes by the name Google Cloud
Composer it's currently in beta but I
highly encourage you to go and try it
out so what we do we schedule our
training pipeline to run daily and each
day we have a fresh model
and the one piece left is that we need
to serve this model in real time so
let's see how we do this exactly just to
recall this is what we want to be order
management application as you as you
remember sense a customer ID and order
detail to fraud service and fraud
service returns probability of this
order being fraudulent how do we connect
that with cloud machine learning one
idea is maybe the fraud service will
just send the features to cloud machine
learning in real time it will get
response and it will just pass it back
to your des management the one problem
here is that fraud service doesn't know
all the features at this point so it
knows what's the current order of the
customer but it doesn't know what was
the past behavior of the customer so we
we need to somehow obtain this data if
you recall we have already calculated
all of this in bigquery so we have all
the features about the past behavior of
the customer already sitting there in
bigquery so maybe we'll just make fraud
service call to call bigquery get the
data for this particular customer and
then combine it with current ordered
data and pass it along to cloud machine
learning again the one problem for that
is big query was not really designed for
random access patterns going to bigquery
finding a row corresponding to
particular customer would be extremely
inefficient and we cannot afford to do
this what we need is some kind of a
persistent cache that will sit between
bigquery and the fraud service so what
we used we used Google datastore Google
datastore is no sq of the human database
so you put entities there with no schema
you can easily search for them you can
have sql-like queries over them but we
don't really use all of those features
what we do is we use Google datastore as
a key value store so we put the data
about customers
as a key value pairs key is a customer
ID and the value is all the features for
this customer so now how do we populate
the data store we'd simply extended the
training pipeline so when the features
are calculated we also use a Google Data
flow to transport these features from
bigquery to data store and this is done
in dataflow with Apache beam again since
Apache Bheema already has connectors to
bigquery and datastore of writing a
program which does the data
transformation was releases just 40 or
50 lines of code and it rounds in a
batch mode and transport the data to a
data store if we combine all the pieces
together training and serving this is
what we end up with if you look at the
bottom of the serving part we again have
order management sending current
features to a fraud service which calls
datastore to obtain the past features
then it combines it and pass along to
cloud ml get the response back so this
is how it works in we are we were pretty
happy with this architecture the one
problem here is that the datastore is
populated every day right it's not
populated every few seconds only when
the training pipeline runs so again the
problem that Lauren described when the
fraudster steals a credit card and she
or he will try to put many transactions
in a tiny time window we will simply not
notice this behavior in our features so
we had to do a little hack and this is
the final architecture for serving that
it's working on production right now so
fraud service now gets the data from
order manage allow concurrent order it
gets past features one-day-old from a
datastore but it also queries other
micro services for the latest data about
the customer so it's all done in real
time and only the inferred service
combines all of
this sense request to cloud machine
learning and gets response back alright
this is how our architecture looks like
and now Laura can you tell us a bit more
about the result that we've got sure
Thank You chemic that's great basically
we have all what we need to run machine
learning on the cloud I can start with
simple feature engineering in Google
bigquery where my data lies extract some
simple feature like counting the the the
past behavior of customer joining some
tables if I need to do more complex data
processing I can use Google Apache beam
in Google data flow for example
normalization I have to do a loop on my
columns compute the average and standard
deviation on numerical columns to
compute my normalized values on
categorical features do some
transformation like one hot encoding for
example or just associate integrals to
the categories and yeah these are some
processing that would have been too
complicated to do in standard SQL and
with Google dataflow it's it's easy next
step I can use data store as a fast data
access to expose my precomputed feature
that i will then use at serving time I
use Google Cloud ml engine to do my
training of machine learning models and
okay let's use neural networks that is a
good conscious decision to go quickly on
prediction and get the best of all what
is offered us by Google cloud once I
have trained my model I can easily
expose it again through Google Cloud ml
engine API and combine it with what I
pre-cum I exposed in the last row of my
pre computed feature I can now run by
prediction of fraud detection in real
time so that's really great and
we are reaching really great results
with with all these obviously if you can
imagine if you compare the machine
learning algorithms with neural nets
with the initial solution that we had of
handmade rules the the results are
really really better when I say
predictive performance sorry
it's not about accuracy because
hopefully failed payment is a rare event
imagine you have one fraud out of 100
orders if you use accuracy to compute
your predictive performance a model that
will just say nothing is fraud would
have 99% accuracy so in this kind of
unbalance class problem we use other
measures like F score or area under the
ROC curve that tried to fight a
trade-off between precision and recall
recall being the percentage of real
fruit that your algorithm managed to
identify and precision being among the
one that he identified as fraud what's
the percentage of right prediction in
this one with machine learning we also
gain adaptability we can really learn
regularly our models and take it to
account the new behavior of fraud
fraudsters and yeah we are taking the
best of the cloud here and we are
already ready to scale with all this
architecture ok so now we have a great
system to predict if an order will be
fraudulent or not what do we do with
that what is the final decision that we
take easily if the order is identified
as non-fraudulent you can just let him
go through and avoid friction with the
customer this is something that Okada
really value rates is just accept
delivery and just accept that the
payment will be done afterwards because
it's it's good for the customer and it's
also easier to handle when you have
some product substitution because what
you asked two weeks ago is is not there
so we propose you something else and
yeah it's it's easier to handle like
that and it's customer friendly on the
other hand if the algorithm says that
another is probably fraudulent what do
we do what do you do with that one
possibility is trigger pre-authorization
on the credit card so you reserve the
amount of the order in advance and to
ensure that the the customer will have
the money at delivery time you can also
ask a fraud agents to look at the order
and take the final decision and this is
where explanation comes back if you can
explain that you think this order is
suspicious for the content of the basket
or the past behavior of the customer or
the payment methods used you can give
this to a fraud agent and yeah if you
want to take this final decision of
counseling and order automatically for
legal reason you have to be able to
explain oh yeah basically I just
presented you the the good result that
we obtained on fraud detection I'm happy
to announce that on the other projects
that we are running product
recommendation demand forecasting and
project recognition we are also reaching
rich really good results with an
architecture that is generic enough to
be used in the same way on different
projects so yeah basically Big Data
machine learning made easy on the cloud
Thank You Google what's next before
thanking some ideas and questions from
you some hints we started to play with
Google data prep that helps you
pre-visualize the data and we find that
this this project is really promising on
the other edge of the pipeline Google
Data studio is a great solution to
monitor our machine learning basically
plot the evolution of
precision and recall of our models and
there is one work that we have started
with the Google asuri team to specified
some service level indicators and
service level objective to ensure the
reliability of our whole system also
also rate thanks a lot for your
attention
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]